THE PRESIDENT AND THE G.O.P.
INTO OFFICE AND PUT AGAIN IF YOU
STAND WITH THEM.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE."
LET'S BRING BACK NEWT GINGRICH
TO DISCUSS THE G.O.P.'S
PROSPECTS, WHICH SEEM TO BE
IMPROVING IN NOVEMBER.
LOTS?
>> I THINK THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
LIKELY TO GAIN 4-6 SEATS IN THE
SENATE.
>> Laura: WE ARE HEARING THEY
COULD LOSE THE MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE.
SIX MONTHS AGO.
>> I DO A NEWSLETTER THAT GOES
OUT TWICE A WEEK FOR FREE AND
TWO WEEKS AGO I WROTE EVERYBODY
WHO WAS WRONG IN THE SPRING OF
'16 WHO SAID TRUMP COULDN'T BE
THE NOMINEE, EVERYBODY WHO WAS
WRONG IN THE FALL OF '16 WHO
SAID TRUMP COULDN'T WIN BACK THE
PRESIDENCY ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON TV RIGHT NOW.
WHY WOULD YOU BELIEVE ANY OF
THEM?
>> Laura: BUT STEVE SCHMIDT
HAS BEEN SO RIGHT.
AND ALL THAT OVER THE YEARS.
I SAY FACETIOUSLY.
>> ALL OF THE POLITICAL ANALYST
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE TALKING
HEADS HAVE A BIAS OF GETTING
TOGETHER AND SAYING THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT AND I
LOOKED AT THAT BOWL TODAY FROM
REUTERS, REPUBLICANS ARE UP ONE
WHERE THEY USED TO BE DOWN TEN
OR 11.
>> Laura: 15 AT ONE TIME.
>> I WOULD BEGIN TO PANIC.
BECAUSE IF THE REPUBLICANS ARE
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO EVEN ON THE
GENERIC, THEY COULD CONCEIVABLY
GAIN SEATS.
>> Laura: DOESN'T IMPEACHMENT
THE DEMOCRATS?
>> YES.
>> Laura: BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICANS, THESE CROWDS AT
THESE RALLIES FOR TERM.
PEOPLE THINK IMPEACHMENT, THEY
WILL GO TO THE POLLS.
I HOPE THAT GUY SAYS THE
IMPEACHMENT -- I THOUGHT IT WAS
ALL GREEN.
HE SAID WE ARE GOING TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S GOING TO DRIVE
REPUBLICANS RIGHT TO THE POLLS.
DEMOCRATS, SOME OF THEM KNOW
THAT.
>> IT'S NOT JUST THE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN WHO IS NOT
DEEPLY POLITICAL ONCE THE SYSTEM
TO WORK.
THEY LOVE WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THE ECONOMY.
THEY LOVE THE FACT WE HAVE THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN
MODERN TIMES.
THEY THINK IT'S TERRIFIC.
GALLUP JUST REPORTED 65% OF THE
COUNTRY THINKS THAT YOU CAN GET
A GOOD JOB.
HIGHEST NUMBER SINCE THEY BEGAN
TAKING THAT QUESTION.
DEMOCRATS VOTED NO ON THE TAX
CUTS AND WOULD NOW LIKE TO
TOTALLY SCREW UP THE ECONOMY BY
CHASING AN IMPEACHMENT ON A
TOPIC THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO HAVE
ANY SUBSTANCE.
>> Laura: THEY GOT PRISON
REFORM PASSED THROUGH THE HOUSE
TODAY.
THAT'S HUGE BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
HUGE BIPARTISAN ISSUE THAT WILL
LIKELY PASS THE SENATE.
PART OF THE DODD-FRANK REPEALED.
THAT'S HAPPENING.
ALL THESE JUDGES, 21 JUDGES ON
THE CIRCUIT COURTS GETTING
THROUGH.
THIS IS GOOD STUFF.
>> USE A REALLY UNUSUAL THINGS.
YOU END UP LOOKING AT VAN JONES,
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT, SHOWS UP AT
THE WHITE HOUSE AS PART OF
PRISON REFORM.
SOMETHING YOU COULDN'T HAVE SEEN
A YEAR AGO.
>> Laura: I THINK THE
KANYE WEST EFFECT IS SOMETHING
WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN FULLY
EFFECTIVE.
>> SECOND EXAMPLE.
KANYE WEST WITHIN THREE DAYS,
BLACK SUPPORT APPROVAL OF TRUMP
DRAWN FROM 11 TO 22.
>> Laura: HOW MUCH OF AN
INCREASE IN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT OR THE
REPUBLICAN AGENDA WOULD
DEVASTATE THE DEMOCRATS?
>> FIVE OR EIGHT OR 9% WOULD BE
DEVASTATING.
IF THE REPUBLICANS EVER GET TO
20% OF THE BLACK VOTE IT IS
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS TO SURVIVE.
>> Laura: THEY ARE TRULY
PETRIFIED OF THAT.
RACISM, RACISM, RACISM.
IDENTITY POLITICS.
>> RIGHT.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WHAT YOU
HAVE IS A PRESIDENT WHO CAN SAY
ABSOLUTELY ACCURATELY THIS IS
THE BEST SITUATION IN BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY
UNEMPLOYMENT IN AMERICAN HISTOR
HISTORY.
NEVER BEEN LOWER.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU THINK IT'S
A GREAT TIME TO BE AN AMERICAN
RIGHT NOW?
IF YOU ARE IN BUSINESS.
LOTS OF STUFF HAPPENING IN THE
CULTURE I'M NOT WILD ABOUT BUT
AS FAR AS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES.
GOOD TIME.
>> A WHOLE RANGE OF INNOVATION.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET EVERY EIGHTH GRADER
SEPTEMBER TO UNDERSTAND
LITERALLY THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO
GO TO THE MOON, THEY HAVE A
CHANCE TO GO TO MARS.
THE WORLD, THIS STUFF IS
CHANGING SO FAST.
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE TO HAVE A SENSE
THEY ARE GOING TO LIVE ONE OF
THE MOST EXCITING GENERATIONS IN
HISTORY AND THAT COULD BE PART
OF TRUMP'S GREATEST LEGACY.
>> Laura: OPTIMISM AND
POSITIVITY.
PELOSI AND SCHUMER, ONE MORE
SELL ON THE BETTER DEAL MODEL,
LET'S WATCH.
>> YOU ARE MEAN.
>> INSTEAD OF DELIVERING ON HIS
PROMISE TO DRAIN THE SWAMP,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BECOME THE
SWAMP.
REPUBLICANS AND THE CORRUPT BIG
DONOR AGENDA TO GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
IT HAS GIVEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
A RAW DEAL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHEN IT
COMES TO DRAINING THE SWAMP HAS
BEEN A COMPLETE AND TOTAL
DISAPPOINTMENT.
THE SWAMP HAS NEVER BEEN MORE
FOUL OR MORE FITTED THAN UNDER
THIS PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU LOVE THE
FACT THEY USE THE WORD FETID.
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING.
>> THE DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT THE
SWAMP, IT'S AN ANONYMOUS
PSYCHOLOGICAL VICTORY.
SECOND, THE THREE TOP DEMOCRATS
IN THE HOUSE BETWEEN THEM ARE
278 YEARS OLD.
THIS IS THE BASE OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN THIS FALL.
VOTE FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
AROUND SO LONG THEY KNOW